Trascrizione: Carlotta Vielmo
Revisore: Sara Fazzini
Sono qui per raccontarvi la storia
del grande aeroplano
che vedete alle mie spalle.
Siamo nel primo dopoguerra,
e il suo progettista, Gianni Caproni,
come tanti imprenditori dell'epoca,
si trovava nella necessità di convertire
l'attività delle sue aziende.
Le aziende Caproni durante
la I Guerra Mondiale avevano prodotto
grandi aerei, pluri-motori,
impiegati come bombardieri
che alla fine del conflitto, ovviamente,
non servivano più.
La grande intuizione dell'ingegner Caproni
fu quella di capire che grandi aeroplani
potevamo essere impiegati
per il trasporto di tanti passeggeri
su lunghe distanze,
in concorrenza ai piroscafi dell'epoca.
Fu il primo ad avere questa intuizione.
E così,
nel 1919,
fu avviata la costruzione
di un imponente idrovolante,
talmente grande da guadagnarsi
il soprannome di Palazzo con le Ali.
Lo vedete qui alle mie spalle,
un aeroplano di tre piani.
Un'idea grandiosa,
potremmo dire,
il primo jumbo jet della storia.
Per capirci,
il primo aeroplano della storia,
quello dei fratelli Wright,
che oggi abbiamo già nominato
e che sicuramente conoscete tutti,
aveva volato meno di vent'anni prima.
E quindi nel 1919,
pensare a un aereoplano
in grado di trasportare fino a cento
passeggeri seduti,
lo vedete l'interno qui alle mie spalle,
era un'idea
di una lungimiranza straordinaria,
forse eccessiva.
Furono infatti molti
quelli che mossero contro Caproni,
criticando aspramente la sua idea,
ritenendola inattuabile
in quanto troppo audace.
"Caro Caproni",
scriveva in un memoriale,
un importante personaggio,
che durante la I Guerra Mondiale
aveva condiviso,
con l'ingegnere,
l'idea dell'impiego dell'aeroplano,
per il dominio dell'aria.
"Caro Caproni,
in passato
hai fatto sicuramente cose grandiose,
ma su questa cosa qui,
mi dispiace,
ti sbagli.
Il futuro del trasporto passeggeri
non può prevedere
il trasporto di tante persone
molto lontano e magari
anche più velocemente dei piroscafi".
"E l'ingegner Caproni?",
vi starete domandando,
"come reagiva tutte queste critiche?"
Lui andava avanti.
Aveva un sogno, lo voleva realizzare.
Ed era convinto della sua idea,
nonostante diversi momenti di sconforto.
E soprattutto era consapevole del fatto
che se il suo grande apparecchio
avesse volato
avrebbe cambiato la storia del trasporto
passeggeri per sempre.
Lo doveva all'umanità
questo grande passaggio.
È il 4 marzo 1921,
è tutto pronto,
all'hangar di Sesto Calende
sul Lago Maggiore.
Ed è un giorno talmente importante,
Caproni ne è consapevole,
che scrittura un fotografo e un regista
perché documentino ogni istante
della prova di volo.
Vi dirò di più,
nella sua testa,
e nei suoi diari,
Caproni scrive che vuol usare
le fotografie e il girato per la réclame
del suo aeroplano.
Sulle riviste,
nelle sale cinematografiche.
È tutto pronto.
Il 4 marzo 1921,
all'hangar di Sesto Calende,
sul Lago Maggiore.
Ma l'ingegnere non si vede.
"Dov'è l'ingegnere?"
è andato a Milano a prendere il regista
che ha avuto un problema con la macchina
e ha lasciato un ordine:
di non decollare fino al suo ritorno.
Ma Federico Semprini,
il pilota collaudatore designato,
non sta più nella pelle.
Sono mesi che aspetta quel momento.
E quindi pensa, per ingannare l'attesa,
di effettuare intanto
una prova di flottaggio.
Tranquilli,
significa
una corsa lungo il lago senza decollare.
L'aveva fatta diverse volte, prima.
E quindi
fa calare il grande areoplano
in lago,
accende i motori
e comincia la sua corsa,
via via più veloce.
Quasi 110 chilometri all'ora
va tutto bene,
quando,
a un certo punto,
mentre sta pilotando, scorge
un qualche cosa,
all'orizzonte,
prima un puntino nero poi, via via,
capisce di che cosa si tratta,
è un vaporetto,
di quelli che portavano la gente
da una sponda all'altra del lago.
Ed è esattamente in rotta di collisione!
Non c'è tempo per pensare
all'ordine dell'ingegnere
di non decollare fino al suo ritorno.
Bisogna evitare l'impatto.
E in un attimo,
il grande aeroplano,
punta la prua verso l'alto.
E un attimo dopo
la punta verso il basso.
Il vaporetto è stato scavalcato.
L'aeroplano è andato distrutto.
Nel suo diario di quel giorno
Caproni scriverà:
"Tutto è perso in un momento,
ma se si vuole progredire
occorre non lasciarsi abbattere
da quanto accaduto,
perché la strada del progresso
è disseminata di sofferenza".
Nel leggere queste parole
ho sempre provato un'emozione fortissima
e mi sono domandata
che cosa avesse permesso a Caproni
di non arrendersi e di continuare
a guardare al futuro con fiducia.
Pensate cosa sarebbe stato
il trasporto passeggeri
o anche solo la sua carriera,
se si fosse arreso
dopo il fallimento del Palazzo con le Ali.
La risposta che mi sono data
è che Caproni avesse imparato
a costruire sui suoi fallimenti.
Questo,
ma soprattutto uno precedente.
Il primo, il più importante.
Lasciate che vi racconti
anche questa storia.
Siamo nel 1910,
quando Gianni Caproni,
il fratello Federico e alcuni amici
provenienti da Arco,
si trasferiscono in brughiera lombarda
per insediare lì la loro attività
di costruzione di apparecchi volanti.
Prendono alloggio,
uomini e mezzi,
all'interno di un hangar in legno
appoggiato a una cascina di nome Malpensa.
E sull'hangar
fanno scrivere, orgogliosamente,
"Hangar ingegner Gianni Caproni".
Fa niente,
se quando piove
o nevica
entra acqua dal tetto
e devono ripararsi
sotto le ali degli aeroplani.
Fa niente,
se sotto il letto
cresce letteralmente l'erba.
Fa niente se per procurarsi il cibo
devono fare ogni volta
oltre una dozzina di chilometri
in bicicletta.
Quei giovani pionieri
sono pieni di speranza
e fermamente convinti del motto
che volere
è potere.
E quindi tutti gli inciampi che via via
gli si parano davanti,
nemmeno li vedono.
E ad onor del vero, d'inciampi
in quei primi tre anni di attività,
se ne presentano parecchi.
Anzitutto l'esercito,
dal quale avevano ottenuto l'hangar
di cui vi ho parlato,
che dopo pochi mesi
rivuole l'hangar
e il campo, di fronte.
E Caproni?
Fa armi e bagagli
e si trasferisce dall'altra parte
del campo, trovando un altro hangar
dove alloggiare uomini e mezzi.
E poi i soldi,
che mancavano sistematicamente.
E qualunque imprenditore sa
che senza soldi è difficile fare affari.
E Caproni cosa fa?
Trova prima un socio
con il quale mettersi in affari,
che dopo pochi mesi
lo abbandona,
poi ne trova un altro,
che lo abbandona
e poi ne trova un altro ancora,
che lo abbandona, avanti così,
tre anni.
Di speranze
e di disillusioni,
in un circolo vizioso
difficile da rompere.
Senza soldi
non si possono comperare i motori
da mettere sugli aeroplani da vendere,
ma se non si vendono gli aeroplani
non ci sono i soldi
per comperare i motori
da mettere
sugli aeroplani da vendere.
Semplice.
E così,
nella primavera del 1913,
Caproni si trova di fronte
la decisione più difficile della sua vita
fino a quel momento.
Lo scriverà nel suo diario
e lo sottolineerà in rosso:
"Medito lasciare aviazione".
E di lì a poco
accetterà
di vendere le sue aziende allo Stato,
per restarne soltanto direttore tecnico.
Sembra la fine di tutto.
Si rivelerà essere l'inizio.
Certo,
fu la fine
di una prima fase
dell'attività produttiva
delle aziende Caproni,
che coincise però
con una seconda e più importante
parabola evolutiva,
che vedrà, alla fine della grande guerra,
Caproni produrre aeroplani
addirittura negli Stati Uniti.
Fine e inizio come due facce
di una stessa medaglia.
È solo
una questione
di prospettiva.
Questa parte della storia personale
umana di Caproni,
professionale e umana di Caproni,
mi ha sempre colpito perché credo
che ciascuno di noi attraversi nella vita
momenti in cui mette in discussione
la correttezza
del volo che sta compiendo.
La grandezza di Caproni
in quelle circostanze
fu quella di saper adattarre
gli obiettivi
ai cambi di rotta che erano intervenuti.
Caproni era
un talentuoso visionario,
un inguaribile
sognatore
ma soprattutto
era un uomo dotato
di magistrale capacità
di resilienza.
E il suo talento poté davvero decollare
soltanto quando fu libero dal pensiero
di trovare i soldi per poter costruire
gli aeroplani,
che in realtà aveva ancora
soltanto in testa.
A Caproni e a tutti sognatori
si deve il coraggio
di non essersi arresi,
perché dopo di loro
quello che prima era soltanto un sogno
anche sola volta hanno fallito,
dopo è diventato possibile.
Se avete un sogno
e ci credete veramente
forse con qualche aggiustamento di rotta
lo potete anche realizzare.
Grazie.
(Applausi)